hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm officially back from my hiatus
now you may be wondering what I've
learned over this period and the first
and foremost thing that I've learned is
how to be the best youtuber that I can
be but in order to explain that I need
to show you something can you come with
me
actually wait take this camera and just
follow me for a bit don't look boom new
car I'm not I'm not out of my mind here
that's like that's right think of all
the things that you can do with a new
car you Wingham 1 2 3 Peter Paul a
married
what can you do with the car what can
you do at the car do you can you do with
the car so you see right he see what I'm
talking about if you have a car you get
respect you get lots of respect you can
do anything for everybody you can do
people favors you can give them rides
and then also like okay this is a more
important thing like sure respect is
whatever and you can go up to like I
don't know Bakersfield if you want to go
up there and die and go to San Diego if
you want to get swarmed at comic-con
Oxnard I did didn't even know there was
a city and the most insane thing in my
mind is the nearest Cracker Barrel to
where I live in LA it's four and a half
hours away in Las Vegas but if I got a
new vehicle that can take me the
distance that I need to go I can take
chica I'm weeping to go to Cracker
Barrel whatever we want we can just go
right we can just go right cool but not
only that like things change
when you have everything that you need
you can go pretty much everywhere so
long as you have a vehicle right so what
do we need to do we need to get a car
okay
so all this adds up to something that we
know how to do all this is spelling out
something very simple something that we
already know we don't know how to do
this so to get the answers that we need
to know we need to call on the one
person that does know exactly what to do
what we're going to be doing what we're
doing here we are
the dude what would he knows how to do
Tyler he used to be a car salesman
before he came out to LA so if I call
him he will know what to do good man
always reliable trustworthy always there
for you Tyler where'd you where's your
face oh are you busy today cuz I got
this thing
very urgent thing had this whole life
changing like conversation with myself
about yeah about how the only thing I
need is a new car and the only thing I
need is help doing that so if you're
busy that's kind of like explosively
detrimental to my cause oh hi hi yeah no
no I would never do that yeah so you're
not like going to a convention today are
you alright so we gotta go with
Plan B Tyler's out so that's the next
best thing
Tyler what's the next best thing for
getting a car if you're not available I
don't know how to do that on my own
research based upon what you mean /
woman I want respect what
all right fine bomb I'm out so I guess
we're on our own that can get me a
respectful respect
attractive older w /m seeking attractive
female girlfriend roommate so now
there's no help at all we knew that from
the get-go
we got to go on our own so dealerships
are fine and dandy but if we don't have
a car how do we get to a dealership
gaming could get us around
we have we have we think about like
exactly what we need then everything
else falls into place right so take for
example like what does a card give you
cart gives you mobility mobility you can
Paul you can haul you know like u-haul
put Nihal we haul Cracker Barrel Cracker
Barrel respect of course thank you okay
for mobility it only really needs wheels
for hauling you need like a lot of cargo
space for Cracker Barrel you need wheels
for respect you need size everyone knows
that the bigger you are hey pay
attention
everyone knows the bigger you are the
more respect you it's like it's like a
factor of like dominance or something in
testosterone like monkey if you're
bigger like you get more respect it's
why cats spread out far like peacocks
have a bigger tail it's why I have the
biggest head in the world what's the
biggest vehicle that we got a semi truck
right no it's that land crawl if it
takes space parts to the lawn pad that's
the biggest vehicle but I don't think I
can get a license for that you need a
specialized in for a semi - I can do a
pickup truck but I don't want to be a
douche actually it's a fact in in Los
Angeles if you have a pickup truck I
know this from experience if you have a
pickup truck you have to pay an extra
fee if the back is uncovered because
it's classified as a work vehicle and
not a regular vehicle so if you're gonna
have a truck and you're gonna cover it
anyway why not have a van
[Music]
anyone la area selling oh man don't
think that seriously my fans know I
don't do from right I didn't say oh wait
van listen it's not suspicious they
didn't ask me why I need a van I just
need a van a white would a white one
why do they say I could not say a white
one why is everyone everyone's assuming
has said a white man I didn't say a
white man was so scary about a van are
they scared of how much respect I'll
have a minivan no that's not even a van
minivans know someone tried to build
this shower in this one it's full wheel
drive which is handy for when we go
off-roading bonding Bigfoot or whatever
or going to a crack it's pretty good
it's got a lot of miles on it but it's
really cool it's got like wood paneling
on the sides it's got a wooden floor
it's got like a seat slash bed in the
back and a lot of storage space look if
it runs well that was gonna be pretty
good right chica yeah get your leash we
got gold
she's so much for accommodating a dog so
how long you been driving uber oh yeah
six months yeah
because I can't afford to pay my bill
that's a good reason what a little speed
easy go get there on time you know I can
get it here easy
you see now you see get the sweet Oh
need to get out of levy thank you hi
this is a mark the guy interested in the
van no she's scared come on hoppy bub
good it starts what do you want crazy on
the road anywhere from Baja all the way
up to northern like just take a road
trip go out no like you like go on a
solo trip for a couple months and you
yeah what's your DM like an Instagram or
something uh
Horrocks cor underscore are okay okay
I think I want it yes yeah no I really
do seriously this is one we're gonna be
able to travel to Cracker Barrel and get
chicken and dumplings and buy
knickknacks
at Cracker Barrel and get respect that's
another thing
Thanks you're always there for me thank
you there you have it we got a van that
was easier than I thought who needs
Tyler yeah how about a van all by myself
I mean you helped but it was mostly me I
was doing the talking there there's only
one thing left to do after this do you
know that
[Music]
good girl okay Wow we did it we got a
van we didn't need anybody's help no
Tyler no nothing you were of great help
oh thank you so much and now we can do
whatever we want we can go around la we
can help people we can take road trips
we can go camping we can just do mundane
it doesn't really matter but
thanks for being there for me so what
should we do next
I don't even know at this point I've got
so many ideas but maybe I could get your
help from it and I think it's only fair
that you get to name the van it was kind
of your idea after all so what do you
think I was thinking like Shamu or
Gwendolen or or Bertha but I don't know
if you got an idea let me know and
thanks again see you tomorrow Omar yeah